[Music]
hey you were back again for one of our
infamous movie retrospective their
infamous I didn't resonate well I'm just
making that okay there's a Cronenberg
movie you know Jenny's a huge fan of
Cronenberg and I like Cronenberg we grew
up with him and he made weird-ass
[ __ ] movies yeah an ad movie oh we
loved all those [ __ ] weird ass movies
bad yeah movies and it was it was kind
of like a parallel universe Hollywood
scene because thought of this [ __ ] was
going on in Canada but we were really we
were kids we didn't realize it was
Canada yeah I don't she could ever like
really occurred to me at the time yeah
in the 70s or 80s like because a lot of
his movies I mean this movie which is
rabid is actually a notable exception
but most of his other movies even though
they were set in Canada and his early
films were famously filmed with Canadian
yes payer dollars like you know for
their film tax shelter deal yeah um they
they could have kind of been set
anywhere but this one is specifically
mostly set in Montreal and they didn't
film it there and it's mentioned several
times that that's where it taking a
corner bird flick was kind of like the
movie version of Skinny Puppy I thought
about it was another which is another
Canadian product yeah they're just they
just kind of have like a skinny puppy
element to them they were different yeah
you know if you know the bad things I
liked about David corner baby
particularly his early movies is that I
liked his juxtaposition of exploitation
with like kind of this high-minded
intellectual type of because he wasn't
like he wasn't like a Roger Corman
figure he was just like pumping out
movies you know the kind of schlocky
movies and stuff I mean some of
kronenberg's movies the subject matter
it could be said to be schlocky but
Cronenberg always kind of approached it
with this really weird like detached
clinical yeah kind of way of looking at
it that almost made it I don't know
there's like a really weird vibe about
I'm gonna come back every time like I'm
gonna come back in time together
if Cronenberg made Cronenberg if he made
albums they would be Skinny Puppy albums
they probably if skinny poppy made
movies there
yeah that's basically what you had going
on yeah there was a very similar yeah
mindset same mindset a lot of times it's
kind of like similar topics yeah and
they kind of had that really weird
quality where they were you could tell
they were condom handmade in a way or as
homemade out of a small scene but the
quality was really good for what they
were yeah I had been wanting to do more
Cronenberg and shutter added some of his
movies among them rabid which we're
gonna do today they also just added the
fly so I definitely want to do that at
some point cuz I think that's probably
one of his best movies yeah that's
probably his highest budget movies yeah
and I think it was his most successful
it's classic they also have dead ringers
and I'd like to get around to doing that
eventually because that's actually my
favorite Cronenberg maybe he's dead
ringers yes the fly was Cronenberg's
version of poltergeist 1 it was at that
one yeah it was easily his most major
movie even though it was completely and
utterly disgusting yeah which I liked
about it though I like that that was
very subversive that he made this gross
ass movie that made all this Barker body
[ __ ] yeah it's all about the body oh
yeah and he's totally fascinated by like
disease and bodily transformation and
stuff like that we went into that a
little bit when we talk about Videodrome
we went into a little baby we talk about
shivers now rabid actually came out in
1977 and it was the movie that came out
after shivers now the interesting thing
about and they're very kind of similar
he doesn't come out and say oh like
rabbit is like a sequel to shivers
because it's not but he's like it's like
a companion piece because they have very
similar theme they have some of the same
actors and stuff like that but what
ended up happening was when shivers came
out like I said he used that Canadian
tax shelter thing I think it costs like
less than 200 grand to make shivers and
it was like a lot more successful than
anyone was expecting so the production
company were like hey and no one of
those movies laying around that's kind
of like that one and he's like you know
I have been working on this screenplay
which at the time was called mosquito
which if you see
rabid you'll probably know why it's
called that um and it was kind of
similar to shivers like a similar kind
of theme but he kind of rushed it into
production now some of the money for
this was also like from the tax shelter
thing I think 200,000 of it was this ad
was actually five hundred sixty-five
thousand this ended up costing and
interestingly enough now probably one of
the most famous or infamous things about
this movie is that it stars marilyn
Chambers in her first non porn role yeah
and she actually does a pretty good job
I'm you know get into that a little bit
later the range that she didn't go on to
make more movies yeah she really didn't
you think that Hollywood would have
called her to do to do the scream queen
type movies yeah I mean it should have
been a good like Linnea Quigley type
characters you know like that I mean
linea Quigley was more of like she was
funnier and like more but you know she
had more of a comedic kind of thing
going on but marilyn Chambers had she
kind of had that wholesome
girl-next-door type of thing kinda but
she also had and I think it served rabid
really well she also had kind of a like
detached innocence to her I want to say
which I think works really well like in
the in the context of this movie you
know what I mean I don't know if she had
that detached thing because she was in
porn or whatever but the interesting
thing about it though was that when
Cronenberg was first thinking about
doing this movie do you know who he
wanted for that role is it [ __ ] Spacek
okay he had just seen her in badlands
the tennis Malick film and he really
liked her and he wanted to get her in
the movie but the production company
said no because they're like well she
has those freckles and she has that
accent you know like the way that's what
made her yeah you like right yeah that's
funny what they said since it's like
supposed to be a Canadian movie supposed
to be set in Montreal they didn't think
it was gonna fly I guess that's kind of
like when they told Arnold that Oh at
that accent you'll never Hollywood you
you can't act Arnold you'll never make
it
yeah okay okay it depends it's like well
you know that was [ __ ] Arnold
yeah without that accent Arnold never
would have made it yes you would have
just been like another debug who's that
dude Dredd yeah yeah Arnold was it made
him distinctive because the height of
what you have to do yeah like you have
to find your thing like even if it's
something that people are like oh you
and your stupid big ears or whatever the
[ __ ] it is but you have to take that and
make that a feature not a bug right you
know what I mean and I feel like [ __ ]
Spacek probably did that yeah but the
interesting thing about that was because
she didn't get this movie I think that
that was what like Brian De Palma was
like hey you want to be in Carrie and
she was like sure and then they
intervene Carrie now the interesting
thing was that in a scene of this movie
where marilyn Chambers is like walking
down the street there's a poster of
Carrie like in the background like at a
movie theater so I thought no it's kind
of a cute little homage but yeah they
didn't want they didn't want [ __ ]
Spacek because of the way she talks that
was really funny ridiculous it was
[ __ ] kitties [ __ ] I know well the
thing is like Ivan Reitman who actually
produced this movie and he was like the
music supervisor on this too I think and
this was like one of his first cuz
obviously later he went on to like huge
success he's ghostbusters and all that
kind of stuff um he actually said hey I
heard that that porn actress Marilyn
Chambers you know which is unfair I
guess to just call her porn actress
because behind the green door which was
like her most famous movie it was like a
huge mainstream success because you
remember in the 70s you know before Home
Video you had a good like a sticky porn
theater to see porno movies yeah you
invited us you wouldn't want to but in
the seventies it was becoming like hip
and cool for everybody to go to porno
theaters and see foreign movies so
behind the green door it actually made
Cambodia ton of money I can't imagine
that because I'd also heard that that
[ __ ] would break out would almost be
like a dab orgy in the porn theater you
know man that's it man I would hide you
had to clean up in there I was just
gonna say I would hate to be the person
that had cleaned it up you got to clean
up the porn theater or those little like
booths they used to be in the back of
the like the video stores and [ __ ] like
that take this see [ __ ]
thank you what they used to call that a
chumscrubber is that what that does I
think that's what that used to be called
why do I know that I don't know but yeah
only you would know that [ __ ] well
somebody else must have known it because
I must have heard it from something I
don't even know about this like Canadian
tax shelter thing them it's my
understanding that deer in that period
was when you know that period just made
Cronenberg yeah that without that period
there never would have been a Cronenberg
well yeah but the thing is is that
really Cronenberg was the only notable
thing to come out of that period
evidently most of those movies were
total [ __ ] and that that government
program didn't work there were some good
ones that came out that I think but it's
sad because they did them tend to be
kind of like lost yeah gems or whatever
well heard that that period didn't last
too long
I mean the government decided that now
because they're like people just
cheating well and it might have been the
case too because they pissed and moaned
about Cronenberg's movies like hey using
these tax dollars to make this
disgusting body horror movies and they
seemed kind of mad about it until
Cronenberg was like yeah but they're
making money then I guess I guess it's
awesome when they were gonna make some
wholesome wholesome I guess yeah you
know don't give money to Cronenberg if
you want like a normal never gonna yeah
but yeah so this movie like I said it's
has a very similar plot to shivers in
the sense that marilyn Chambers plays
this girl named Rose and her and her
boyfriend whose name is Hart Rose and
Hart isn't that funny I never realized
that until I just re-watched the movie
there at the beginning they're just like
you know in love or whatever and they
get on a motorcycle and I think this is
this part set in Quebec I think it's
like a rural type of thing so they're on
a motorcycle like going down the road
and meanwhile there's also this little
clinic one of what I'm David
Cronenberg's famous like creepy weird
medical clinics they're like this the
weird like brown building and like the
sign with like the bad logo on it yeah
it's you could tell that he's like
really ramping up for you know
the brood and Videodrome and yeah it's
going in there distrustful of medical
institutions in general yeah and and
people don't bring in God's domain you
know I don't blame him you know that
look at the damn industry that did the
uh that did the painkillers yeah what's
this one that everybody's [ __ ]
addicted to now that opioid crisis came
out of that they knew that people would
get addicted to that yeah that family
was a family that did it the thing about
this one now it's like I feel like in
shivers shivers was like a more lurid
story I guess because it was like a sex
virus and it was like a little penis
worm and it turned out what Y is I guess
it was yeah it was like a dick worm and
it kind of turned everybody sanger and
it turned everybody into nymphomaniacs
yeah whereas this one is almost it's
almost his take on a vampire story but
also a disease story now I think he
might have been inspired as many people
were by the 1973 George Romero film The
Crazies which is one of his lesser seen
ones but it's actually really good
ending that it was actually a big
inspiration for Danny Boyle he made 28
days later to do like the whole rage
virus and like zombies but they weren't
dead people and they were really fast
and you got infected really quick so I
feel like that idea you know has been
inspired and I feel like Cronenberg
might have been inspired by that as well
so in this one marilyn Chambers
character rose her and her boyfriend or
a motorcycle accident and it's kind of
near this weird clinic that I get it's a
plastic surgery spa essentially is what
it is you go there and you get plastic
surgery and then it's like a resort and
you hang out till you're all healed up
or whatever so they get into a wreck the
boyfriend is mostly okay I think he just
breaks his hand or some [ __ ] like that
but she is all busted up and she's
burned and stuff like that so so they
send an ambulance there's no other
Hospital closeby
so they take her to this plastic
surgery clinic now the doctor that's
there decides hey here's a guinea pig
although you know I mean she's gonna die
if they don't do something but he's kind
of like oh I have this experimental
procedure and I'm will try it out on her
because she's she can't tell me that I
can't pretty much now what he's talking
about essentially is skin grafting but
he does something with the skin grafts
like before like he has to send them out
to a lab so they can be quote-unquote
neutralized it's almost kind of like a
stem-cell thing where it's like we're
gonna take this part like off your ass
or whatever and we're gonna stick it
somewhere else and the skin will you
know adapt to that part of your body
that we stick it on which sounds pretty
reasonable and I think they kind of do a
similar thing nowadays but at the time
it sounded a little bit Frankenstein
yeah I guess because this was 1960 1976
1977 so they give her this treatment
she's in a coma for like a month or
something like that and then she wakes
up later like her boyfriend is
subsequently gone home and he's been
coming back to visit and stuff and for
whatever reason I don't know if they
grafted skin into her armpit and that's
where the problem occurred because it
seemed like they grafted skin sort of
everywhere they had taken skin off her
thigh and put it someplace else but she
wakes up and she has it's either it's
like a mouth or vagina or a butthole or
something it's like it looks like
something like that in her armpit and
you don't see it until later but it has
like a little stinger penis ii thing in
it that comes out like a big wasp
stinger and sucks blood like a vampire
but with your armpit yeah that's a lot
of stuff when you see it it is a
mysterious process what they're showing
it is I mean I'll just cut over this you
have 70 I don't know in a minute I don't
really remember them explaining how this
happened I know they didn't screw that
through this happened yeah it's a good
movie right you know what I mean it's
just like that's what happens when you
let doctors [ __ ] around with
experimental procedures without
permission suddenly you have a bottle
armpit yeah that shoots out stingers and
sucks blood from people yeah it had
teeth on it too didn't it no it was like
a it looked kind of like a big
caterpillar because it's seeing like a
spike it doesn't seem like she put her
arm around people to bite in there be
blood and then it's sometimes I don't
want to get into it it was a just a it's
like a big wasp sting yeah it was weird
it was weird you know and it's
Cronenberg trying to trip you out yeah
it was pretty the movie is shot pretty
it pretty well it starts off with a cool
motorcycle scene yeah the quality of it
when you look at look at it on shutter
up is blu-ray quality is yeah they
shared it in 2007 yeah I want to say
they did it right around the same time
they've restored shivers they've been do
I think arrow DVD has been doing all the
Cronenberg yeah it looks pretty good um
you can tell that it's an early
Cronenberg movie it's not quite as I
would say technically good as what you
would see in like the brood yeah it's
definitely one of his transition yeah
like I said shivers was basically his
first full-length feature films so this
is only really his second thing with
shivers is that I found shivers to be a
lot more of a conventional movie in
terms of the way the edit and the story
went yeah it's very watchable because
it's a lot like other movies of the
genre yeah this one you could tell he's
really trying to do his own thing it is
weird yeah it's weird but I don't really
think he's not as competent in this
movie as he became later yeah I mean the
Videodrome was like the beginning of
Cronenberg Sam [ __ ] yeah I do the [ __ ]
my way and you know he's taking you with
it yeah with the movie so what it is is
it if you asked me this one is kind of
like a glimmer of the Cronenberg to come
oh yeah you know it's there it's just
see that he's not really on top of his
craft yet yeah that's good
it's really good movie to watch yeah if
you're into this kind of [ __ ] yeah and
you can definitely see where a lot of
his like later obsessions and themes
like came from and I think we probably
talked a little bit about this more
shivers - I mean shivers like I said it
was basically a sex parasite and it took
place pretty much all in one apartment
building right it's like at the end they
were like oh we're gonna go out and
spread it or whatever now in this movie
um you know it costs he got like you
know twice the budget to make it so it's
on a much larger scale yeah because what
happens is that when she once she starts
like biting people with her armpit
stinger um she drinks their blood and
that's all she can drink like she can't
eat normal food anymore cuz when she
tries to eat food she just throws it up
so she just has to like taking blood
through her armpit and but she starts
spreading what is essentially a rabies
type virus so people will get it and
then like it incubates for six to eight
hours I think they mentioned and then
that person starts foaming at the mouth
and starts raging and starts going after
and trying to drink the blood what you
end up with is almost kind of like a
cross between a vampire story and say
like a typhoid mary type situation yeah
it's like that
she is essentially like and in a way I
think even though it was sort of
accidental that they cast like a former
porn star in that role vd yes she was
like a walking venereal disease that
essentially because she was going around
now the tragic thing about her character
though is that one it wasn't her fault I
mean she was in a motorcycle accident
she was you know against her will she
was given these skin grafts you know she
was in a coma so she couldn't like
consent to it and she ended up with this
[ __ ] thing in her armpit and then
when she wakes up she has this blood
lust and she doesn't really you know
understand it so she escapes from the
hospital she goes and starts you know
trying to drive from a cow she drinks
our farmer all this other stuff but she
doesn't realize that she's spreading it
like she doesn't realize that she's
patient zero you know what I mean so she
runs away from the clinic she's
hitchhiking she gives it to like all
these people and she ends up in Montreal
and it starts spreading and it spreads
to such an extent that you know they
have to declare martial law because
people are just getting rabid all over
the place and you know there's a great
scene where she's in a mall it
said at Christmastime - just for added
shittiness and you know the army has to
come in cuz there's like a rabies
outbreak like in the mall or whatever
and there's Santa there and he's like
taking a picture of the girl they just
start shooting everybody they [ __ ]
shoot Santa they just like in the mall
and the mall this Dan Bella's [ __ ] I
mean nowadays these are dead malls it's
like a 70s mall it went in you're our
age it takes you back to our childhood I
remember you remember when malls look
like yeah everything was like dark brown
with dark brown damn there's brick
planner Grayson yeah yeah brick [ __ ]
spotty benches yeah most of those are
torn down now we're dead now yeah that's
one of the things that fascinates me
about watching movies from the 70s
I don't it's weird because I don't have
nostalgia in the sense that I'm like oh
I wish I could go back to that time
because I don't want to because a lot of
it was really ugly yeah but in cheap
yeah yeah but it fascinates me being
like oh yeah when I was a kid I remember
you know that when a bench looked like
that or that couch or I remember that
package that Nakajima like I remember
when jello had that box yeah I mean it's
like it's just weird to revisit [ __ ] you
forgot about one scene they zoom in a
person's picking something up off of a
desk or something and they zoom in on
the desk and I saw a pair of damn
glasses and they were clear like
sunglass yeah it had glitter inside the
plastic and I just had like a damn
massive flash I was like I remember the
glasses look like that it's [ __ ] when
they had that oh that shit's little
thing yeah because I haven't seen him in
forever but you remember kind of big
things like I remember like what my
family's cars look like and stuff like
that but whenever you see a movie from
the time period and like I said you see
like packages in their kitchen or like
you know a pair of shoes or something
like that it's not something you
wouldn't necessarily remember but then
when you see it yeah and it like makes
like a weird little thing we're watching
we're watching last night another 70s
movie called the car car we've got a
possessed and yeah and the quality of it
of it was really good like blu-ray
quality James Brolin and yeah yeah we're
gonna do a review on that it was
excellent movie actually yeah but that
movie reminded me how
shitty paint on cars used to look yeah
there's gold paint quality paint was
like terrible everything that's
everything was city in crap everything
was brown well and the paint didn't have
any depth to it yeah it was like the
paint that you would paint on the walls
of a school cafeteria and you got that
[ __ ] on the car there's been nasty yeah
it's just funny how like cheap and
crappy everything yes like I said it so
I'm not nostalgic in that well I
wouldn't mind going back just a visit
for a few days yeah but I know time you
don't want to live back in those days I
remember dating I remember it that
sucked a lot the only thing that was
good back in the 70s was the pizza pizza
back then was better than pizza now
y'all kids don't know what pizza really
tastes like with that Buffalo cheese and
real crust homemade crust like it round
Table Pizza old round table from the 70s
yeah [ __ ] well you know what's
interesting is that I mean I grew up in
Daytona Beach we're just kind of
rednecky it's still kind of redneck it's
a lot bigger now than when I was growing
up but I don't even remember what I
liked when I was a kid we had Pizza Hut
but it was sit down yeah it was better I
don't think we had pizza delivery until
I was older like dominoes and stuff I
don't know we had that because bad we
got pizza when I was a kid we always
went to the mom-and-pop place yeah a
mile away and got pizza from their mom
pocket areas were better yeah and
there's sausage and onion Pantheon pizza
it was like it might still be there I
don't know I'm a long time this is dinky
little dive but there's sausage and
onion pizza was like a hamburger
I remember when Little Caesars was great
I don't I don't remember that yeah yeah
it was it was really good better like
Hungry Howie's no settles no it was good
it was good in Michigan during like 86
it was good really I'll take your word
for it yeah it was it was better than
say I'm just saying yeah yeah there was
a time it was good
I need AMA knows was always kind of
mediocre it was a media
mediocre too bad it's alright if you're
having a party and you need a lot of
food for naught but don't a movie review
talking about My Goddess on pizza but
the crowd loves this [ __ ] I'm gonna do
another thing that I liked about rabbit
I love that David Cronenberg
I love the [ __ ] names he comes up
with for these [ __ ] characters like
the [ __ ] main doctor this clinic is
called Dan Kelly he always says like
names that almost sound like alien very
well it was cool about this period
convex or whatever that guy's name was
from video drew what was cool about this
program that this period in filmmaking
and in the film scene was that this was
the time when the bromance
okay the bromance 15 Cronenberg and I
said I meant it I forgot to do a thought
tip tip of my tongue
dude this skate from New York and all
the other ones John Carpenter this is
about when that time started to form and
John Carpenter you know was watching
these movies and giving shoutouts to
Cronenberg you know they were buddies
but this is where a lot of that stuff
started around this time that is one
thing like I said I'm not nostalgic for
going back to that time period but I
will argue with anyone that cares are
you that the 70s was probably the Golden
Age of horror not saying that there were
and there's great horror movies from
every decade actually you know the 80s
were also fantastic 90s were a little
but there was some good stuff that came
out then but I feel like it's gotten
better in like the last you know 10 20
years with them some really good ones
the 90s was a little bit of a dry period
but the 70s I think produced probably
the most classic yeah because she had
Romero and all these guys they were
starting to catch their stride and it's
because a small filmmaker didn't
necessarily have to be well-connected
with Hollywood and he could be in his
local area raising local money making a
[ __ ] cool film it was very much in
line with the punk rock right right and
the other DIY I put in the in that and
the good ones were rising to the top the
mediocre ones were you know like that
like you know Legend of Boggy Creek and
all those guys they were kind of in the
but the good ones will rise to the top
and then later on we're being become in
Hollywood stars so yeah it's very much
like the punk rock scene yeah I mean you
know and that's something I really like
about that old because you have to think
you know now everybody you know
everybody could have a youtube channel
[ __ ] we've got everybody everybody movie
everybody can make a movie it's super
cheap yeah um but the 70s work that you
know late 60s early seventies that was
kind of the first time that that it ever
happened where the technology was coming
but enough that somebody that would do
it if you really want it and then there
was this whole attitude about you know
do your own thing you don't need to be
within a system you can just make a
movie and it was like guerilla
filmmaking and [ __ ] like that so that
was kind of the first time that that it
really happened at least to that large
of an extent yeah and some of them the
ones that ended up being successful
famous like Carter Burke you know um
they actually in carpenter
you know they made good movies yeah you
know some of them did a lot of them just
disappeared but yeah I mean a lot it was
a Darwinian it was a Darwinian process
of the good ones rising up yeah even
even a lot of the shitty ones that were
made in the 70s are still pretty
entertaining yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess
you could say so
yeah yeah so I say watchable you can
laugh I don't mind that at all and
really that kind of thing went on into
the 80s it's just that if you hadn't
really made it by 85 you probably
weren't gonna make it
yeah because I feel like by 85 yeah by
that time it had kind of started to
decline a little bit yeah and guys like
Cameron and everything and Hollywood
started to swallow up the good in
depended good ones and independent they
started to becoming you know into the
system yeah you know they were you know
they wanted him to become unionized all
that too you know and use their friends
yeah but you know like I said it that
that whole time period you know it
pretty so many auteur somebody like
great [ __ ] movies yeah and I mean
Cronenberg among them and he's probably
like I said
aside from David Lynch
it's probably my very favorite Lynch
director you know so so I've tried to
see like all of his movies even the ones
that are kind of like you know
considered not as good this one is kind
of considered one of his lesser films
because it was an early one but like I
said it's it's not quite as weird it's
not as weird as Videodrome it's it's
pretty gory um you know it's it's got a
lot of his signature kind of stuff that
his signature kind of body horror stuff
yeah but it's it's still pretty it's a
larger scope than shivers which was like
his first movie and it was like I said
it was very contained in one location
this one was like citywide and I think
they did a good job of that if you've
never seen a Cronenberg movie I don't
recommend this one I wouldn't start with
this no don't start with I would
actually start with the brood because
the brood is watchable and that'll draw
you into it and then you can go to
Videodrome and that's that tops the
brood yeah then you can go back and
watch some of the other movies that he
made you know and the fly really that's
his most crowds is the most
crowd-pleasing one but this isn't as
much special to it if you asked me
yesterday it's not a mainstream well one
cuz it's conventional oh yeah it is good
though yeah and a lot of people have
argued that it's his best film and I'm
not gonna dispute that assertion it's
not my favorite film of his but I really
do like it yeah but since it was sort of
a you know a loose remake you know it
does kind of have a more traditional
movie type of thing it's not as weird
yeah it's it's super gory which that's
always a plus but it's it's not as weird
like tonally it's not weird it's not
like like I said from that time period
I like Dead Ringers a lot better because
yeah that is a strange yeah I forgot
about that that was a good movie now
they're creepy [ __ ] movie but if
you're listen to this review and you've
never seen a Cronenberg movie don't see
this one first yeah this is like a deep
cut like go to the brood first that is
this first reliable to him I would see
the breeder video drum first yeah I
would go brood and then video drum yeah
you know I mean that way there's like a
it rises yeah you know
yeah that's true scanners scanner
scanner scanners one none of the
immediate none of the other scanners
honestly it's funny because they did
Netflix or shutter somebody put scanners
I remembered scanners to being good
because I saw it recently that was like
we watched arrabal I watch I didn't see
I don't think Cronenberg get anything
you do know I did it
scanners t1 was awesome movie disturbed
me when I did that disturb that's for
the main guy that was the main actor in
it he was a little yeah I would go
breather
I would go brood Videodrome scanners in
that order if you've never seen and then
go back and see then go back and you can
see the old ones because I mean I feel
Cronenberg is still making movies
nowadays he's kind of gotten away from
the horror genre horror sci-fi genre a
little bit you know he did history of
violence obviously he did Eastern
Promises both of which are amazing
amazing movies but they're more crime
type movies quite like mime dramas not
really um you know [ __ ] not really
straight horror or not or sci-fi I think
they also have eXistenZ I think on
shutter which is one of his I want to
say later movies even though it was like
1999 or something we watched it the
other like it was like a virtual reality
game Jennifer Jason Leigh was in it yeah
except it was like an organic pod Dead
Ringers I think was better I would I
would go honestly like I said and this
may be in an unpopular opinion I'm not
really sure but Dead Ringers is easily
my favorite David Cronenberg I would go
Videodrome is my second I would go brood
video drum scanners Dead Ringers
and then the other one end the fly yeah
I'd watch him in that order and you'll
be pleased yeah he said [ __ ] he has such
like an idiosyncratic yeah vision and
like I said some of his earlier films
it's not quite as much on display cuz he
didn't have the big budgets it's like he
wasn't like you said he wasn't as
confident as a filmmaker but if you like
shivers you definitely have to see rabid
cuz it's like a companion piece you know
they're very similar in tone even
rabbit is a lot larger scope it takes
place over the whole city of Montreal
right shivers a rabbit we're both good
it's just that yeah I think for a
younger person those movies are kind of
dated in there yes I wouldn't show ya
those first because they actually might
turn a younger person off yeah I think
I'm talking about yes they're very 70s
they're very 70s brewed will actually
bring some a new person right into it I
think
yeah brewed that's just a weird movie
did we do a review on the bird I think
we did I think we've done so many
reviews on it we did a lot of like I
said rude just kind of disturbed me when
I was a kid that's like it's kind of a
[ __ ] up me I mean because these movies
you know like like I said rabbit and
shivers very much concerned with like
infection um whereas the brood was more
like reproduction weird yeah like this
weird like reproductive psychological
and what was that what was that pretty
guy's name
the British guy who played the the
doctor who did Oliver Reed Oliver Reed
yeah Oliver Reed was a dude that always
seemed to be like one drink away from
whipping your [ __ ] ass he's scared
you knows he was yeah yeah yeah I think
it was that was the correct
interpretation [ __ ] got one
more drink in him he's gonna whip my ass
yeah he's a good guy but there was
something when you're a kid that there
was something intimidating about it you
can meet on the edge of crazy yeah I
think that's what made him a good actor
though yeah
great British actor look how good he was
in [ __ ] in that haunted house movie
that we did yeah yeah yeah I'm one of a
cool kansai it's hard me to remember
people's people's names like that dude
that dude from the hand Michael Caine
okay
Michael Caine was another British guy
that was one drink away from whipping
your [ __ ] ass too yeah they were like
wife beaters man it was funny cuz
they're kind of like classy but then
they're like got got an element of toxic
masculinity or the one more drink I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up then they made really
good dramatic
horror movie players well like I've
always been of the opinion that they
were intimidating really great at
something creative whether it's a guitar
writing work you have to be a little bit
crazy
yeah the both of those are easy it
you're just gonna it might be alright
but it's just gonna be like mediocre
yeah maybe like genius you have to be
kind of crazy both of those dudes that
were gifts to American cinema though and
guess you know North America oh yeah
you're not gonna get near your kid
getting it better for this Michael Caine
I like to know boys damn yeah and like
we said we talked about this a lot to
you like I'll back in the day like in
the 70s they'd be on the talk shows like
Merv Griffin or yeah yeah classic maybe
like all [ __ ] scotches yeah yeah we
our show is inspired by that generation
will sit there well drink we're talking
about [ __ ] yeah they'd be drinking
while they're [ __ ] talking on Merv
Griffin yeah when the show is over they
go back to the hotel and like bang
seventies girls yes 70s girls old Bush
yeah don't see that much nowadays well I
saw I've heard it was another time Super
Furry and actually now that you mention
it getting back to rabid there was one
scene in this the first dude that
marilyn Chambers attacks like he doesn't
know what happened to him because she's
just like hey I'm cold c'mere hug me and
then she's like what the [ __ ] happened
like he didn't know and then like later
he goes and he's like laying down the
thing and he's like his armpits all
bloody and [ __ ] and while he was laying
there I know I was supposed to be
looking at his bloody armpit but all I
could look it was this mat of chest hair
yeah and I'm like yeah [ __ ]
didn't know better back then no she's a
manscaping man what the [ __ ] is that
about
all's it takes is a Bic lighter you can
smell like it looks like he has a shirt
on but he's terrible for sure terrible I
thought that [ __ ] was macho back then I
guess there's a hide the fact that you
didn't have pecs
yes Fanny well it's just like how people
grow beards to hide double chins
yeah
I'm not hating it's a you know it's hey
man whatever you can do that's cool 70s
was another era they didn't have the
same standards of physical fitness yeah
man they did and they weren't bothered
by body hair no it's not like because
they watching the car last night and all
those cops and everything had a little
bitty arms yeah you know they have a
little bitty arm and what was the guy's
name is star his name again
James bro James Brolin actually had some
school swagger to him though though he
remind you of my dad my dad kind of
looked like that yeah kind of a macho
no-nonsense attitude not so intelligent
to be nerdy you know me dumb enough to
be brave you know they must have the
devil in it we're gonna have to do a
review on that because I was so
motivated to because I checked shutter
every day or every couple of days and
they must have just added it like the
day before a recording yeah not a bad
movie the car actually that movie held
up pretty well other than the Edit in
the final scene it's hard to tell where
the car was during the final conflict
well they're like well where's carpet
somebody I don't know well they probably
did that a bruise that [ __ ] bar you
don't want to like run over any of the
stuntman so you know we have to like cut
all these things together the premise of
a possessed car run around killing
people might be good on the surface I
know 70s was a car culture it did have
kind of a Mad Max okay no it's not it
wasn't it Rick the scene in the in the
garage where it teleported in there what
that was kind of effective I wonder if
that's where slugging King got the idea
for Christine probably or from a Buick
eight probably also Maximum Overdrive
you know
Maximum Overdrive and all that probably
just that that premise doesn't didn't
age well see I wonder like I know that I
can't remember if dual the Stevensville
yeah TV movie did that come out before
after this with check but is Ron that
seems well because the thing is I mean
I'm not gonna say well Richard Matheson
wrote the short story which feed which
dual was based on and I
that I'm sure that came out before the
car right because I think that what was
that 76 the car was 77 77 yeah okay so
I'm pretty sure that the story that it
was that the duel was based on before
therefore that cuz that was richer man
they we're all playing off I have to
know somewhere over there like I have a
rich Matheson story that's called you
could probably redo that today but you
couldn't you couldn't confine the evil
demonic force to the car itself you
can't do killer car I have to come out
of the car sometimes and they get it
back in the car no psychic forces you
can't do killer carcass has been done to
it bender yeah yeah I mean Christine was
probably like the definitive you don't
you could have a demonic being driving
into monic car in the way the ghost
rider rides into monic motorcycle you
could probably do that yeah I think the
seventies I think the seventies the REIT
I think I think they were kind of
limited by budget and special effects
they probably would have like something
in the car to come out and [ __ ] people
up remember the window would roll down
you they and they would look through
there but they would never show you what
it is that they saw well I thought there
was nothing in it yeah but I think that
was just an excuse I think they wanted
something in the car they couldn't
afford it right well it's just like in
those old movies where they're like well
we can't afford a monster suit so let's
just say that the monster is invisible
right like pretend that you're fighting
an invisible monster hmm I'm looking at
you at or have anything else to say
about this movie oh okay so couldn't
wrap it up so let's wrap it I know we
talked about it it's a decent flick but
I just wouldn't start with this flick if
you don't know yeah I would recommend if
you were new to Cronenberg's you know
body of work I would I would recommend
starting like you said with the brood or
video drum one of the two or even the
fly even though that's kind of like it's
really good but it that's like that's
not a strong rosenberger II it's not as
representative right yeah of his work
and then like maybe a nurse yes Janice
yeah go back and see some of the old
ones so like I said shivers and rabid
rabid should probably be seen kind of
later on I would think there and well
and they're very sim
like the things are very similar like
infection it's just like spreading to
other people and stuff like that he was
the master of body horror yeah yeah yeah
right alright so we're gonna wrap this
review up and remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media if you'd like to
financially support show you can go to
our patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
cast or you can go to our blog 13
o'clock podcast on WordPress com and
there's a PayPal button in the sidebar
where you can give a one-time donation
if you'd like to do that it'd be much
appreciated and remember these movie
retrospectives just like this one it's
usually old movies but sometimes not
these come out every Friday and we also
have 13 o'clock matinee which is three
new movies in the theater that comes out
every Sunday and our regular episodes
which is paranormal or sure crime type
stuff or whatever it is we feel like
doing that comes out every Tuesday so be
sure to check them out and we will see
you next time bye